okay next game again with black versus
uh master yoda from france
also a pretty good player two four
five seven okay and he declined um
to a benko
yeah e5 is the most principled move here
but
i don't know it really
yeah this is also an interesting line
where black grabs the pawn
but white um has got very decent um
compensation
we will open up the game later
with e4 rook c1 and stuff like that
it's um it's not easy to play
i make sure to have the opportunity to
go to
b6 oh maybe maybe he's got
bishop c7 now
not sure
okay let's retreat all the way
yeah white has a huge um development
advantage
and he will open up the game okay
but take now
yeah i think i need to take
i'm not sure do i want to
castle first oh
no idea what's better here okay let's
castle first
alternative was to take here
yeah the only good thing um about
black's position is
that i am i don't have a pawn weakness
or something that you can easily attack
so um it's it's still fairly solid but
of course he's got a huge piece activity
he's got um a good chance to maybe get a
pawn back
on c6 yeah i think he's going for that
okay maybe rook d8
to to pin this
i always need to be um ready to
maybe return the pawn or someone c6
to get the pieces out okay this pin is
annoying though
not sure what he's doing
maybe queen b3 or something
that's it's my knight is also pinned so
yeah he went for queen b3
i also have knight d5 maybe that's a
good idea
to um
to get um to use this this outpost here
yeah i expected that and then yeah
bishop c5
my idea was that i might get some play
on the b
file
some counter play
okay i guess i need to i need to take
this first
okay
yeah he has got no no easy access to c6
at least
because of the night
okay is he threatening to take there
really
not sure maybe he is
hmm
okay i need to speed up
so
try to um get at least a good um
position for the knight here always um
attacking a2 and it's got the somewhat
weird queen position
between a4 or something i can play
knight d3
also i could try to play um
bishop to e8 attacking the knight
i need to um
also i think i need to spend a move soon
with for
g6 or something to solve my background
issues this could be a problem
okay interesting move
i thought a form maybe okay i need to
need to play quicker
interesting
okay
yeah it's still not not easy for white i
think
i always have some ideas on b2 and a2
and so on
and this time is running down
okay
plane knight a6
knight a6 d4 is hanging yeah
knight essex
time warning okay
does he do
okay let's chop this off
and what
okay now
this little trick here
cannot cover b2 now
nice let's time run down
this is convenient oops
yes still
okay didn't look too hard for a really
great continuation
because of the time situation
white forfeits on time maybe this
wasn't necessarily the best but i was
winning on time anyway just check
quickly
do i have something better here
no this was actually the only move
yeah okay then then it's maybe just a
draw
did i have something better this look
very suspicious
not sure
with knight knight b3 it just takes
a8 i think
okay i can i can just take b2 here
ah this might be it might be the real
issue i can take b2
yeah i was somewhat tempted to get this
pin
in here on the first rank
but i can i can just capture on b2 yeah
it's still not easy of course but
this would be um would be better to to
get some winning chances in the game
after okay maybe here maybe he has some
other move
king e7 or something
i mean instead of this here
if he goes to the second rank of the
king i can still check
so maybe um maybe king e7 maybe trying
to
threaten king d6 or so yeah i think this
might be might be a better winning try
but
it's still it's so difficult okay